The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So today
I'm mostly going
to talk about two
formulas that we are
going to make a lot of use of.
One is the time derivative
of linear momentum,
which will be used a lot,
has got to be equal to,
for a particle.
We'll just do particles today
and then rigid bodies soon.
So for a particle, this
is just the mass times
the acceleration
of the particle.
The rigid body, it's the
total mass times acceleration
in the center of gravity.
And the other formula that we've
learned, that we've come up to,
is the sum of the external
torques with respect to a point
A on a particle is the time
derivative of the angular
momentum of the particle
at B with respect to A dt.
And then it's got this nuisance
term, this velocity of A
with respect to O cross the
linear momentum at the point B
with respect to O. So we
talked about this last time.
So this is a particle
that's located out here
at B. There's some
intermediate point A. And we're
computing the angular
momentum of this particle, m,
with respect to A.
And A can be moving.
And if it is, when you
go to compute torques,
you have to use this
kind of messy formula.
We often try to
simplify the problems
that we do so that we
can either make A a fixed
axis of rotation--
make it rotate
about this point, in which
case this goes to zero--
or there's another
time when you can make
the velocity of
this point parallel
to the velocity of that point.
And the most common
one of all is
when you use this formula
about the center of mass.
Then the velocity of
the center of mass
is the same direction
as the momentum.
And therefore, this
term goes to zero.
So we have these two cases
where this formula simplifies.
So the way we most
often use it is
the summation of the
torques with respect to A
is just the derivative of
the angular momentum dt.
And that's it.
This is when vA is zero, or
vA is parallel to P, such
as A is at the center of mass.
So these are the two
formulas that we want to use.
Let's just do a real
simple case first.
And this is just my mass
on a string spinning
around, constant speed.
I'm going to pretend I'm
on a frictionless table
so I don't have to
deal with gravity.
This thing is horizontal,
just spinning around.
And I'll call this point A. This
is my point O. This is x, z.
No, y.
It's looking down on it.
So it's going to have a velocity
in this theta hat direction.
And you've got your R hat.
We'll just use polar
coordinates to do this.
So the velocity of A
with respect to O we
know-- and we'll give this
just a length magnitude r1.
So this is going to be
theta dot equals a constant.
r dot equals 0.
So it's just fixed length.
Fixed length is r1.
So we know the simple
formula for the velocity
of that is r1 theta dot in
the theta hat direction.
[INAUDIBLE] hat, excuse me.
And the momentum then is
just the mass times that.
And the time derivative
of the linear momentum
with respect to this
fixed reference frame
is the time derivative of this.
This is constant.
The only thing you have to take
is the derivative of theta hat.
So this is mr1 theta dot
theta hat time derivative.
But we've worked that one
out two or three times.
It's theta dot--
minus theta dot r hat.
We'll put that in.
You get minus mr1 theta
dot squared r hat.
And this must be the sum
of the external forces.
And if we're,
looking down on this,
draw a free body diagram of
our mass, looking down on it,
here's r hat.
The theta direction like this,
z coming out of the board.
So this is x, y, and o.
There is a inward
force on it that we
call the tension in the string.
And some of external force
is just minus Tr hat.
So T is mr1 theta
dot squared, which
is what we talked about
just a second ago.
So this is just a
demonstration of what
we were talking about
with the survey questions,
that when you spin
something, you're
changing its linear momentum.
Not in magnitude.
It stays constant.
But it's constantly
changing in direction.
And the direction
change-- you have
to take this derivative--
gives you the [INAUDIBLE].
Direction changes causes the
centripetal acceleration.
To cause that acceleration,
you have to put a force on it.
And the force is that inward
tension in the string.
OK, so that's the first
really simple one.
Now, let's take a [INAUDIBLE].
Now let's do the same
problem, but let it
be a little bit more general.
I've got a tabletop.
This problem's described
in the book as an example.
You've got a hole in the table.
You've got your mass out here.
So this is looking
down on the table
and down through
the hole, coming out
the bottom of the hole,
you have this string.
And you pull on it.
So r dot-- so we're
looking down on it.
This thing, again,
has some theta.
r hat directions like this,
theta hat directions like that.
This thing's spinning, going
around and around my table top.
But there's a hole
in the tabletop,
and I can pull the string
and shorten the string.
So r dot's a constant.
Theta dot will
not be a constant.
it will change.
This is my vector r.
So the velocity, we'll call
this A. This is my origin,
O. The velocity in this case
of the particle with respect
to the fixed inertial frame
is r dot r hat plus r theta
dot theta hat.
So now it has two
possible velocities,
and I'm going to
be pulling it in,
and it's going to be
going round and round.
So the linear momentum is
just mvA with respect to O.
So with this problem,
if I take the time
derivative of the linear
momentum, you recognize this.
This is just velocity
in polar coordinates.
We've done this derivative
before to get the acceleration.
So the acceleration, it's
the time derivative of A
with respect to
O is acceleration
of A with respect to O.
And that's a messy formula,
and we've derived it before.
So that looks like--
and it's got four terms.
r double dot minus
r theta dot squared
and the r hat plus r theta
double dot plus 2r dot theta
dot in the theta hat direction.
And if multiplied
by the mass, that's
the mass times the acceleration.
And this would be equal to the
sum of all the external forces
acting on that particle.
That's Newton's second law.
But in our problem here,
I've said this is constant.
So I can throw out this term
that's going to be zero.
So this term goes away.
But this term's
certainly not zero.
This term is not
necessarily zero.
This term is certainly not zero.
So what can we do with that?
So now's the time you draw
some free body diagrams.
And let's look at the side view.
The side view,
here's your particle,
mg down, some normal force
up, and a tension pulling in.
So the table's supporting
it, gravity down, and just
the string force pulling it.
In the top view, you're
looking down on it.
I'm not allowing
them to-- assuming
it's a frictionless table,
so there's no friction.
So the only force seen from
the top is the tension.
There are no forces in the plane
in the direction theta hat.
So the sum of the external
forces in the theta hat
direction are in this direction.
This is-- so the total forces on
this thing from your free body
diagram in the theta
hat direction are?
AUDIENCE: Zero.
PROFESSOR: Zero.
And that allows us to take this
term and set it equal to 0.
This is the x.
So the theta hat
piece is equal to 0
is equal to m r theta double
dot plus 2r dot theta dot.
[INAUDIBLE] solve this
for-- that's equal to 0.
So r theta double dot equals
minus 2r dot theta dot.
So in order for this thing
to satisfy Newton's law,
it happens to be that
as you pull it in,
the product of r
dot and theta dot
gives you the
angular acceleration.
And the other term, we
just went through that.
So what we did a
couple minutes ago.
The force in the
r hat direction,
sum of the forces--
this is a derivative
of the linear momentum--
is minus mr theta dot
squared r hat.
And we know from the
free body diagram
that that better be equal to
minus T in the r hat direction.
So just like
before, it tells you
that T equals mr
theta dot squared.
So the mass times the
centripetal acceleration,
in order to make that
centripetal motion happen,
you have to pull on it with
a force mr theta dot squared.
So what can you say about
the angular momentum
of this particle
with respect to O?
So let's write it out.
So H of the particle
with respect to O
is rAO cross P. This
is r r hat cross P.
So r cross r, you get
nothing from that term.
r hat cross theta hat gives
you a k, a positive k.
So you get r r squared theta
dot in the k direction.
And I'm missing something.
There we go.
m r squared theta dot.
mr theta dot is the
linear momentum times
another r gives you
the angular momentum,
m r squared theta dot.
And because r hat
cross theta dot is k,
this angular momentum
is directed upward
about the center of rotation.
So that's our expression
for our angular momentum.
But if you take the
time derivative of it,
what should it tell us?
Let's go back to our
formulas we started with.
When the center of
rotation's not moving,
when the point with respect to
which you're taking the angular
momentum doesn't
move, then that's
one of the cases where you can
get rid of those extra terms.
So in this case, we're
computing the angular momentum
with respect to O,
which doesn't move.
The velocity of O here is zero.
So this allows us just to say
that the sum of the torques
with respect about O is
just equal to the time
rate of change of H
with respect to O.
And to do that, this
term can change,
and this term can change.
But how about the
derivative of k?
It's just constant, right?
So we're going to get
two terms out of this.
We're going to get m2r
r dot theta dot k plus r
squared theta double dot k.
What are the external
torques in this problem?
You're going to have
to pretend that I'm
on a frictionless
table top here.
When I'm going around
like this, what
are the torques about
the center point?
So what are the-- first,
what are the forces
acting on the mass?
Just the tension.
And the tension
cross the moment arm,
the tension's in
the r hat direction.
The string is in
the r direction.
r hat cross r hat is--
AUDIENCE: Zero.
PROFESSOR: Zero.
So there's no torques.
So for this problem,
this is equal to 0.
And that then allows us to
write-- the m cancels out,
obviously, and I
can get rid of-- one
of these r's goes away.
And I'm left with
an r dot theta dot.
And I move this
to the other side
equal to minus r
theta double dot.
And that's what we came
up with a minute ago
when when we did
the time derivative
of the linear momentum,
we learned this.
So we haven't learned much more.
It's just telling us
that, well, this thing's
going to accelerate.
It should pull it in.
And it'll accelerate
at any instant
in time, whatever r dot
is, theta dot is, this'll
be the angular acceleration.
So what will happen then?
And let's do it at
two points in time.
And we'll let r2
equals r1 divided by 2.
So I'm just going to
pull this thing in.
So let's do the experiment.
I'm going to pull it in
about half its length.
It can speed up, slow
down, stay the same speed.
I'll get it going and then--
and I'll try not to hit you.
I'll move over here so
I hit him instead, OK?
Let's try it again.
All right.
But there's no torques on it.
There's no torque being applied.
The angular momentum
is constant,
and yet the thing speeds up.
So I want to ask you a question.
Do you think the kinetic
energy is staying the same
or changing?
So how many think the kinetic
energy as I go from out there
to in here, the kinetic
energy stays the same?
OK.
How many think it's different?
All right.
How many are not so sure?
Let's find out.
So we've determined
that if this is zero,
then that means that h with
respect to O is a constant.
So h-- this is at T1-- is r1.
Be faster if I look at my notes.
So the angular momentum
at r1 is mr1 squared
theta 1 dot in the k direction.
And that had better
be equal to h at r2.
And that'll be mr2
squared theta 2 dot.
And that's also in
the k direction.
But we know that r2
is r1 divided by 2.
So we can plug that in.
I'll bring this over here.
So mr1 squared theta 1
dot is mr1/4 theta 2 dot.
So I can solve for theta 2.
So if I shorten the
length by a factor of 2,
the angular velocity
goes up by a factor of 4.
And let's check
the kinetic energy.
Kinetic energy state
1, 1/2mv1 squared.
That's 1/2mv1 is r theta
1 dot quantity squared.
So what do I have?
I have some
expressions for this.
r2 is r1/2, and theta 2 is 4
theta 1 dot quantity squared.
And if you multiply
that out-- yeah.
So where's the kinetic
energy come from?
AUDIENCE: You're adding
energy into the system
by pulling down.
PROFESSOR: So she says we
add energy to the system
by pulling down.
So we're doing some work, right?
There's tension in that string
equal to mr omega squared.
If you pull it down a
certain distance-- in fact,
r1/2-- you're going
to do work that's
the integral of
the tension times
dr. You integrate it, right?
And that work goes into--
there's conservation
of energy in the system.
That goes into speeding
up the rotation,
and yet the angular
momentum has stayed constant
throughout the action.
So when I first
saw this years ago,
I thought, that's really cool.
That's really quite amazing.
So a nice application
of conservation
of angular momentum.
An application of using
this formula, the time
rate of change of
angular momentum
with respect to a
point, it tells you
about the torques
applied to the system.
And this is in fact
a pretty simple case.
So the last-- let's
move on though to doing
a little more complicated case.
And this is similar to the
last problem in the homework.
So this is like the homework.
The homework, you got this
monkey running up the shaft,
right?
So I don't have a monkey, and
it's not running up the shaft.
But I do have just this
particle on a shaft
rotating about a central axis.
Now, this is a
mechanical necessity
to hold it all together.
But let's just ignore
the mass of this center
piece for the moment.
Just think of this as a massless
arm with a particle on it.
And I want to calculate
angular momentum.
I want to calculate forces.
I want to calculate torques
and see what happens.
So I'm going to start by
putting my O, x, z frame right
on the level with this mass.
What I'm going to
show you now is
that where you put the reference
point about which you compute
the angular momentum matters.
You get different answers
depending on where you put it.
So I'm going to start
by putting it here.
And this we'll call
[INAUDIBLE] out here's
my point A. Here's O. This
is some angle phi here.
And if this has some length
l, then this up here is my r
equals l cosine phi.
And this side would
be l sine phi.
These are just the
two lengths, but I'm
going to use polar coordinates.
So this is going to
be my r hat direction.
Theta hat's into the board.
So let's compute--
and it's a particle,
so I'll continue to
use lowercase h of A
with respect to O-- it's a
vector-- is r of A with respect
to O cross P linear
momentum with respect
to O. This is r r hat.
We just call this l cosine
theta, just calling it r.
It's in the r hat direction.
Cross with P, and P, we'd done
this two or three times now
today.
It's the mass times
r times theta dot.
That's its speed.
And it's in the
theta hat direction.
So taking the r hat cross
theta hat gives me k.
So I get m r
squared theta dot k.
Very simple expression.
Now, this is a
fixed axis rotation.
So I want to
compute the torques.
Look at my formula.
The vA in this case
is the velocity of O.
The point of the axis of
rotation doesn't move.
So the second terms
go away, and I
can say that the torque of my
particle at A with respect to O
is just dhA dt.
So m's a constant.
r's a constant.
k's a constant.
The only thing that has a
time derivative is theta dot,
and it becomes theta double dot.
This is m r squared
theta double dot k.
And that is equal-- well,
that's equal to the sum
of the external torques.
So what physically
does that mean?
What physically is
that telling us?
It's telling us theta
double dot is the angular
acceleration of this
thing speeding up,
going faster and faster.
It takes torque to
make that happen.
If it's going at constant
rate, what's theta double dot?
Zero.
So at constant rate,
the torque required
to make this thing go
constant rate is zero.
Makes sense.
But if it were
speeding up, if you're
making it go faster
and faster and faster,
it requires torque to drive it.
And that's the amount of torque.
And the torque is
around the axis of spin.
Pretty straightforward.
So if I did dP [? d, ?]
if I took the time
derivative of just the linear
momentum for this particle,
we've done it here today.
If I took the time derivative
of it, what would I get?
It's a force.
And what's the force?
It's a constant rotation rate.
Take the time derivative
of P. dP dt gives me
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Mass times?
PROFESSOR: Mv squared over r
is mass times acceleration.
The acceleration is which kind?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Centripetal.
So you just get the
same thing back again.
So there's a force acting
inwards words this thing
to make it go in a circle that
is the mr theta dot squared
term that we've
seen so many times.
But now what I want to do is
move the point about which I
compute this angular momentum.
And now I'm going
to put it here,
the point of
attachment of the arm.
So here's O, x, z.
Everything else stays the same.
All I've done is move the point.
And I want to compute
the angular momentum
of this A with respect to O.
Well, that's r.
This is now r of A with
respect to O, this vector.
This distance here, in polar
cylindrical coordinates, is z.
And this is r.
Just as before.
The r hasn't changed.
And there is an r hat
in this direction,
theta hat into the board, and
a k hat in the z direction.
Those are our unit vectors.
So this is-- rAO is
r r hat plus z k hat.
That's the position vector.
And I'm going to cross
that with the momentum of A
with respect to O.
And the momentum
is mr. Theta dot
is the velocity.
And what's its direction?
Theta hat, right?
Mass times velocity, momentum.
And now we need
to carry this out.
The r hat term times
theta hat gives you a k.
m r squared theta dot k.
And this term, k cross theta
hat, gives me a minus r.
Minus mrz theta dot k.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: You're right.
Thank you.
Because I would have a disaster
if I let that progress.
This looks like that, right?
k cross theta is minus r hat.
r cross theta is a k.
k cross theta is a minus r.
I get two terms.
And this is now an expression
for the angular momentum of A
with respect to O. And let's
see if I have enough room
to draw it here.
There is a piece of it here.
This is h in the z
direction, is this arrow.
And then there's a piece in
the r hat direction, like this.
This is h in the
r hat direction.
And the sum of
those two is that.
So this is hA with
respect to O, this guy.
Perpendicular to the shaft.
It will turn out it
really is perpendicular
if you work out the numbers.
Totally different result
than when I did it here.
So this one, m r squared theta
dot k, m r squared theta dot k.
Hey, that term's the same.
So when I did this, I
got just the k term.
And now I've moved this thing
down, and I get a second term.
So now what we want to know
is, what about the torques
in the system?
So I want to take
the time derivative
of this guy with
respect to-- the time
derivative of the
angular momentum, which
is going to be equal
to the summation
of the external torques
with respect to O,
but O is now in a
different place.
And so I have to carry
out these derivatives.
And this one I did before.
This one just gives me my m r
squared theta double dot k hat.
Now, this term, m is a constant.
r is a constant.
z is a constant.
Theta dot is not
necessarily a constant.
We're going to let
that be a variable.
And r hat is certainly
changing direction.
So when I take the
derivative of this,
I'm going to get two terms.
So the first one is minus
mrz theta double dot r hat.
And that's taking the derivative
of this multiplied by that.
And the second term
is the derivative
of this multiplied by that.
And so the derivative
of r hat is?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Theta dot theta hat.
Right.
OK.
So minus mrz theta dot
theta dot theta hat.
So in other words,
this is squared.
Now I have three
terms to mess with.
We know what the
first term means.
We talked about that.
This is the torque.
These are all torques.
So this is the torque required
to do what, the lead term?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] circle.
PROFESSOR: To make it?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Go faster.
Change its angular speed, right?
It's just building up the
angular momentum in that spin.
So this is the angular spin up.
These other two terms,
these are strange things.
Well first, let's take a look at
this one. r theta dot squared.
What's that remind you of?
What kind of-- torque is usually
some force times a moment arm,
crossed with a
moment arm, right?
So we know that there's some
forces acting in this system.
It's spinning.
We know that there
is a-- in order
to make this thing go
round and around-- it
has centripetal acceleration.
Therefore, there must be a force
being applied by this shaft
inward that's equal
to the mass times
the centripetal acceleration,
mr theta dot squared.
So here this guy is
That's the force.
And let's do these.
Let's call this A. Let's Call.
This term here B, this term C.
So the C term is-- torque C,
I'll call it-- is
some r cross some F.
And the F, I'm telling you, is
the centripetal acceleration
times the mass.
And that'll probably
be like a minus mr
theta dot squared r hat, right?
And what about the moment
arm that that acts about?
What moment arm is
perpendicular-- so
that's a force that's acting in.
What moment arm is
perpendicular to that?
Because the only thing
that's perpendicular to
it lead to torques.
PROFESSOR: Hm?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: z.
k cross r should
give me a theta.
Sure enough, there's
a minus, sure enough.
And there's the z.
You multiply this out,
you get this term.
So this is a strange term.
It's in the theta hat direction.
What is that?
So it's spinning, and
it's lined up like this.
Theta hat's in that direction.
Positive k, positive
theta, positive r hat.
k's in that direction.
It's telling you
there's a torque
being applied about this point
in the minus theta direction.
Does that make sense?
You have a-- there's a
centripetal acceleration
times a mass.
There's a force
times a moment arm.
This force is trying
to bend this thing out.
If this thing had a hinge down
here, and I started to spin it,
what would it do?
It would just flop out, right?
There's got to be a torque
keeping that from happening.
And that's a torque.
If it wants to go
that way, there's
got to be a torque going the
other way keeping it in place.
And that's what that term is.
So now we know.
So this is the Euler.
This is the spin up.
This is keeping this
thing from flopping out.
What's this guy?
This is yet another torque,
and it's in the r, minus r,
direction.
So let's see if
we can intuitively
figure this one out.
Well, there's an r
theta double dot.
That should look familiar.
r theta double dot.
If this thing is accelerating,
angular acceleration,
speeding up, out here that
mass says, I'm here right now.
In order for me to go
a little bit faster,
I'm accelerating
in that direction.
There must be a
force being applied
by this rod in that direction.
And that force times a moment
arm perpendicular to it, z,
is a moment in the r direction.
So as this thing spins
up, if this thing could,
it would fall back.
But this rod is stiff
and won't let it do that.
So this is the
torque down here that
is required to keep
this thing moving.
So this is really quite amazing.
Do either of these torques,
these second ones, this one
and this one, do they contribute
to-- do they do any work?
Do they add energy
to the system?
See, work means force
through a distance.
They don't do actually any work.
They are static
torques just required
to hold the system together.
This one does some work.
It actually makes-- this one
leads to energy accumulating,
just going faster
and faster faster.
These are just holding
the thing together.
But the amazing
thing is that you
can use angular momentum
to calculate things
like these torques.
So if you were designing
this, these forces
acting on this lump out
here are producing torques
about this point, which are the
same thing as-- in 2.001 you'll
be doing bending moments.
It creates a bending
moment in the shaft.
And if you don't make
the shaft strong enough,
it'll break it off.
So the torque about this
point is the bending moment
in the r direction and
in the theta direction.
It's trying to be bent
in two different ways.
And you can calculate the
stresses down here caused
by those moments.
And that would help
you design the thing.
So you not only get
dynamics information
out of taking things like
the time rate of change
of angular momentum.
You get some of the static
information as well.
The other thing to remember,
the really important point
of the lecture, is
that angular momentum
changes depending on where
you pick a reference point.
So when we picked the reference
point just opposite it,
we got none of the information
about the torques down here.
Because with respect
to this point,
there are no torques
except the one speeded up.
The centripetal force here
doesn't cause torques.
The force out here-- there
are no other torques, just
the one to make it spin faster.
But as soon as I
move it down here,
I learn something of
considerable value.
So the homework problem
has some of the same things
on it, except the
monkey's moving.
So you get even
a little bit more
interesting
information out of it.
All right.
So that went faster
than I thought.
So that gives some time
for some questions.
I could see several.
So we'll start there
and then go here.
AUDIENCE: What
exactly [INAUDIBLE]
torque B is balancing out?
PROFESSOR: So say again?
AUDIENCE: Torque B
[INAUDIBLE], what
exactly is that balancing out?
PROFESSOR: This term?
You're asking about this term?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK.
You want me to explain
again what this one means?
This is a term associated with
increasing the angular speed.
So let's see if we
can't-- so this B term,
I'll call it the torque
associated with B,
minus mrz theta
double dot r hat.
Now, that is going to
be some r cross some F.
And if we can get
some physical insight,
if we could figure
out what they are.
So the mass, the force, is the
mass times an acceleration.
There's an acceleration
r theta double dot, which
is the speed of this
thing is increasing speed.
And the r is going to be z.
z k hat cross-- and I'm
guessing that it's a force that
looks like mr theta double dot.
And this is in the
theta hat direction.
k cross theta hat
gives me minus r hat.
r hat and the minus.
So this looks like a plausible
explanation for where
this might have come from.
So this is the force
speeding up, attempting
to speed up this mass.
There's a force pushing on it
that's given to it by this rod.
This rod is pushing on
it to make it go faster.
Mass times acceleration
would be mr theta double dot.
And the moment arm
is this distance
from here down to
the point at which
I've been computing my reference
point from here to here at z.
So force times z,
r cross F, puts it
in the-- ends up in
the minus r direction.
It's got to be this
direction, k cross theta hat.
The force is this way.
Think about this.
Force is that way.
The r is this way.
The r cross F is this way.
And that's where you
get the minus sign.
It's in the minus
r hat direction.
But it comes from trying
to speed up this mass.
And if this was a floppy, weak
link, as it tries to speed up,
it would try to bend back.
It would flop back as this thing
tries to make it go faster.
It will say, no, I
don't want to go.
Lay back on me.
And that would we going
in the-- this way,
to keep from doing
that, you have
to put a torque on it this way.
Just trying to speed up.
It's trying to lay back,
and you're saying nope,
can't do that.
Go like this.
So that's the B term.
AUDIENCE: If you do the problem
with a situation like that,
how do you know where to set it?
PROFESSOR: How do you
know where to set it?
Well, that's a good question.
He's saying, when you're
doing a problem like this, how
do you know where to
pick the reference frame?
Well, ask yourself what
it is you want to know.
And in fact, now that you know
that from angular momentum
of mechanical things,
you can actually
get static torques
on the system,
ask yourself where you
want to know those torques.
In this case, if
you're designing this,
you want to know whether you're
going to break this thing off.
And it's probably going to
break right down at the bottom
where the moment arms
are the greatest.
So that's why you
pick that point.
It comes a lot with experience
will help you choose.
But the amazing thing
is this information's
all stored in the
angular momentum
if you pick it in
the right place.
Another hand.
OK.
Yes, Phillip.
AUDIENCE: I had a question
about the direction for r hat.
I thought it had to
come out of the origin.
But you have it going
in the x direction.
PROFESSOR: So I've
been using polar-- he's
asking the direction of r hat.
So I've just been using
polar coordinates.
And polar coordinates is
cylindrical, technically.
This problem has a z
direction upwards, r direction
radially outwards, r hat,
and theta as drawn here
would be into the board, given
the position of the mass.
Looking down on it, here's
my O. And looking down,
this would be my x and my y.
And this is some random
arbitrary position here.
And this is theta.
Looking down on
it, in this plane
is r hat theta hat, k hat
coming out of the board.
Side view, x, z, and
my system is like this.
Now the theta is into the
board, and the r direction
is this way.
That's r hat.
And this is z.
This is the
z-coordinate upwards.
So the position vector, the
thing we call rA with respect
to O, is indeed the length
of this whole thing.
But it is made up of a
component in the z direction
plus a component here that we
call r in the r hat direction.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] example
where we calculated from
the bottom rather
than the top circle,
then we got a value for
the angular momentum that
doesn't have a
theta hat component,
but as the thing spins--
PROFESSOR: Which are
you referring to?
Are you talk--
AUDIENCE: h about
the point O down--
PROFESSOR: Which
example, this guy or--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK, so point.
Tell me what you mean here.
AUDIENCE: Right
here. [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: When we computed,
not here, but down here.
AUDIENCE: We got that there
was no theta component,
but as this spins around,
theta is changing.
And if it's always
opposite, shouldn't there
be a theta component?
PROFESSOR: A theta
component of what?
AUDIENCE: Angular momentum.
PROFESSOR: Angular momentum.
She's asking, shouldn't
there be a theta component
of angular momentum?
So we compute our angular
momentum with this formula
at the top.
It's an r cross P. So the
r consists of the z part,
and the r part is
exactly this right here.
And the P is only
into the board.
It's only in the
theta hat direction.
So you have a term that's r hat
cross theta hat gives you a k,
and you have a
term k cross theta
hat, which gives you an r.
There just are no
cross products that
come out of this that are
in the theta hat direction.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So if it's just
at this one position,
then you don't have it.
But as it spins--
PROFESSOR: Ah.
In this case, that's why
polar coordinates are nice
because as it spins,
the theta hat's
just constantly going with it.
The r hat's constantly
going with it.
And so the beauty
of this thing is
this is an axially
symmetric problem.
It goes round and round, and
the torques are given out
in this rotating frame.
I think maybe what's
confusing you,
is if you wanted to know the
torques in a fixed inertial
frame, you'd have to break
them down into ijk components,
which you could do.
A little tedious.
But the answers in this one came
out in r hat, theta hat, k hat
terms.
Happy to answer.
This is good stuff, but thick.
So keep-- other questions?
So what do you think will happen
in that final homework problem
with the monkey running--
now he has some velocity.
How will that problem
differ from what we've done?
Do you have a question?
Do you want to answer that?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Well, [INAUDIBLE]
monkey [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: It's going to what?
AUDIENCE: Look like a circle.
PROFESSOR: It's going to
look like a circle, OK.
He'll be going in
a circle, at any--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
as in a spiral.
PROFESSOR: A spiral.
He'll be going
like a helix, huh?
All right.
Yeah, the monkey will be
going in a helix, yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: What forces
will act on that monkey?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: In what
direction do you
think there will be forces
acting on that-- he's hanging
on for dear life, you know.
This thing's going around.
They could throw him off, right?
So what forces act?
And if you could
figure out what forces
act-- so you draw a free
body diagram of the monkey.
There's going to be possibly
forces in the theta hat
direction, in the z
direction, in the r direction.
But just think physically
where they come from.
So we now know
that certainly he's
hanging on because
he is undergoing
centripetal acceleration.
And in order to force
him to go in that circle,
there has to be an inward force
applied by this shaft to him.
So there's a force
like that because
of the centripetal acceleration.
If it's speeding up,
there's a force pushing
him to make it go faster.
But he's running up the shaft.
What else is there?
Are there any other
accelerations?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] angular
acceleration [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, there's
angular acceleration.
That's the thing
trying to speed up.
And so he's hanging on because
this thing is accelerating,
like pushing you back
in the car seat, right?
Linear acceleration.
Well, this is trying to--
at any instant in time,
it's trying to go faster.
So he's having to hang
on because of that.
So that's one of those terms.
But now he's moving.
He's also running up the shaft.
Will that lead to any
other accelerations?
And force equals mass
times acceleration.
So every time you
can-- if you can
account for all the
accelerations in the system,
multiply it by m.
You've accounted for
all of the forces, sum
of the forces of the
mass times acceleration.
If you add a new acceleration,
you better add a new force.
If you add a new force, you'll
probably add a new torque.
AUDIENCE: So we have
to account for gravity?
PROFESSOR: Well, gravity, yeah.
What else?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So he's suggesting
there might be a Coriolis
acceleration.
And the Coriolis
acceleration, in order
to make the monkey accelerate,
according to that term,
there will have to
be yet another force.
And I think-- so we'll
see if that turns up
in the calculation.
You've got a couple minutes.
I want you to do
the money cards.
Think about-- and
then on your way out,
I think just pile them up
down here on the table,
or hand them to me
or one of the TAs.
And that'll help me
understand what you understood
or didn't understand today.